what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
come my children gather around papa rob
has another instance of killing
superheroes yes we're gonna kill some
more superheroes by the way I can't be
too loud because it's it's around eight
or nine o'clock at night right now and I
don't want to serve the neighbors too
much but you guys for whatever reason
love it when we kill superhero how to
kill a superhero so in this video we're
gonna be talking about the flash now
here's the caveat what we're gonna do in
this one is we're gonna do this sort of
well-rounded conversation about the
flash itself the flash concept and then
in future videos we'll actually focus on
the different versions of the flash
Wally West Barry Allen Kid Flash new 52
Wally West so on and so forth and the
reason why is because as a general rule
the Flash's ability is really just
SuperSpeed but different versions of the
flash can use that SuperSpeed for
different effects and so because of that
we're actually gonna kind of dive into
these individual characters in different
videos and kind of focus on how you
would kill Barry Allen how you would
kill Wally West with regards to their
abilities to use a Speed Force in a way
that is unique to them now for those of
you guys who are not familiar with the
Speed Force is basically an extra
dimensional energy that exists in DC
Comics that gives all the speedsters the
powers within the DC Universe now the
powers that these individuals can derive
from a Speed Force include SuperSpeed
enhanced agility and reflexes super fast
healing enhanced endurance and almost
instantaneous metabolism the ability to
generate and throw Speed Force lightning
and the ability to vibrate the molecules
that make up their bodies to allow them
to face through solid objects and so
this is basically the power said that
we're gonna be dealing with with the
modern-day incarnations of the flash
that we're gonna be talking about
although something to keep in mind is
that the golden and silver age flashes
did not have some of the powers listed
here but again we're gonna be focusing
on the modern versions of these
characters so the question is this how
does one go about killing someone that
they likely can't catch well in the
instance of Barry Allen he's actually
died in the comics before and the crisis
on Infinite Earths event in the
mid-1980s and how this happens is
basically the very runs so fast in an
effort to stop the ante monitors
antimatter cannon from firing that he's
literally transformed into the same
lightning bolt that struck the lab where
he was working in the past causing him
to be covered in the chemicals that
turned him into the flash and so while
it appeared that Barry Allen had died
it's more accurate to say that he was
merged with the Speed Force
instead of actually dying as we see
later on when Barry leaves the Speed
Force during final crisis number three
in 2008 and so for those of you asking
hasn't the flash died before the answer
is yes and no but either way we're
looking to find a way to actually kill
the flash not just trap him inside the
Speed Force or send him back in time now
obviously the biggest obstacle to
killing the flash is doing it quickly
enough that he wouldn't have time to
react which is nearly impossible in
addition to being able to run at super
speeds the flash is also able to think
and react at super speed as well which
makes getting the drop on him a daunting
task so unless we happen to find the
flash asleep and kill him before he
wakes up we're either going to have to
do something hittable of taking him out
instantaneously or slow him down to
negate his super speed now as we think
about our options it's important to
remember that although the flash is able
to move at speeds that seem to defy the
very laws of physics that hold the
universe together there are certain
forces that still limit what the flash
is able to do most notably gravity and
friction what I mean by this is that in
order to run the flash needs to be in an
atmosphere where gravity is at normal
level and where there's a surface to
provide friction for him to run on and
that leads us to our first option which
is to either increase or decrease the
gravitational pull of whatever area the
flash is in if gravity is increased it
should slow the flash down to some
degree although I'm not sure to what
degree gravity would have to be
increased to slow him down to normal
speed on the other hand if gravity were
decreased the flash would be unable to
push off from the ground with enough
force to propel himself forward and a
fast enough rate to travel at super
speed now both of these are
theoretically possible ways that we can
slow down the flash enough to kill him
since without moving at SuperSpeed he's
just as vulnerable to death as any other
human but we can't really say how
practical they are because we don't know
to what degree we would have to either
increase or decrease gravity another
option we have is to decrease or
eliminate friction which in turn would
negate the Flash's super speed now this
has actually been done before in comics
specifically an issue number 35 of Scott
Snyder's Batman run where Batman's
battling the Justice League after
they've been infected with the Joker
toxin in this issue Batman uses a suit
of armor than he's specifically designed
for battling the Justice League should
the need ever arise and in the conflict
he's able to spray a frictionless
substance on the ground as a result the
flash Koreans helplessly out of control
into a building and is knocked
unconscious
now once unconscious the flash would be
come vulnerable to being killed and even
if we don't manage to knock him out it's
unlikely he'll ever be able to get up
and escape while the frictionless
surface is under his feet and so this
seems like it would be an effective way
of preventing him from getting away and
thus allowing him to be killed believe
it or not however this is not the only
way Batman has come up with a way to
take out the flash in the tower Babel
storyline which I have a video on if you
want to check it out Batman had created
a bullet that vibrates at a frequency
sufficient enough to make the flash
experience seizures at the speed of
light and so that gives us another
option and really reinforces the notion
that when it comes to figuring out how
to kill superheroes in the DC Universe a
good first step is to see what plans
that we've seen Batman use just in case
it ever comes to that but we don't
really need to copy what Batman's done
because I think I've come up with a
pretty foolproof way of taking out the
flash bear with me here so the first
step is to get him in an aircraft on
some sort that unbeknownst to him has a
bomb powerful enough to blow up the
plane that's attached once a plane is in
midair you detonate the bomb taking out
the plane and the flash with it the
truth be told I don't think simply
pushing him out of the plane would work
because even though the flash couldn't
have a surface to run on he's actually
demonstrated the ability to create
whirlwind by moving his arms in a
circular motion so he could possibly
cushion his landing and survive that's
why I think the best option is to do it
quick and easy with an explosion that
takes him out instantly it doesn't give
him much time to react and he's in an
enclosed space so there's really nowhere
for him to go and escape the blast but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end another video
under our belt on how to kill
superheroes and again let me know down
in the comments section if you guys are
interested in seeing me take it in turns
with like very Allen or Wally West or
the new 52 Wally West or something along
those lines again it might be kind of
rough just because of the fact that a
lot of their powers are pretty similar
so because of the fact that they've kind
of changed and evolved over the years so
we might have to like pick the
individual characters at their peak when
they were at their absolute best and
really kind of go from there but if the
guys are new here to comics explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core the guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]